[Music]
another beautiful day here in sunny
California
just kidding it's gross but we're
excited because Warner Brothers has done
a complete Lego makeover of the posters
of some of their biggest shows and honor
of the Lego Batman movie and let me tell
you guys awesome Laureus day for an
interview right welcome to the et into
carpet we bring it anywhere
you guys are Legos now how awesome is
that it feels real good tears of
happiness about being a Lego that's true
I mean this is actually my second time
they actually made the Legos you can
probably take this home I'm sure you
guys can make it happen come on where's
those Legos at the EP carpet exactly
it's not gonna fall over there's someone
behind us Andi it's it's messy not fix
it the secrets of Hollywood you just
hire someone to prop things up for you
how cool is this you're a Lego we we are
Legos and and now our cast photo has
been emblazoned in Lego on the side of
our Warner Brothers lot my children have
them the first thing my older son wanted
to do was put me on Darth Vader's body
then he wanted to put me in a chicken
suit
then he wanted to put me on the toilet
so I am I am a Lego and my children can
torture me as a Lego oh this is so cool
I'm a big kid at heart I grew up with
Legos and they even incorporated that in
the show the middle so to be able to
have not only our poster beyond the
Warner Brothers walls but now have it be
a LEGO version of the poster it is like
so awesome that is so cool and I heard
there's but Legos actually exists that's
so cool that I actually exist as a
minifigure oh no it's awesome every
kid's dream is to become an action
figure but now you're I feel anything
here I'm a minifigure that's even better
it's starting to rain folks it's
starting to rain my hair but what about
my hair Batman Batman moment would be T
Batman the man of the hour
Lego Batman please join us on our red
carpet how comfortable are you you I
think you're the warmest person here
today you're a star now on the side the
Warner Brothers a lot you also have your
own movie can we get like a reaction to
you starring in your own film also who
designed this frock you look gorgeous
can I get a fist bump for a Lego Batman
movie cool alright Batman folks Batman
oh thank you very much for stopping by
will arnett have to get back to work
alright guys gotta get out of here it's
starting to rain and my hair does not do
well in this weather lego batman movies
out February 10th go check it out bye e
thanks for watching ET on youtube but
wait wait before you go there's plenty
more where that came from all you got to
do is hit the subscribe button